welcome to the second session of the bio
conference live for cancer research
discovery and therapeutics my name is
Michael I'm bunting and I'll be your
moderator for this presentation on
behalf of Life Technologies I'd like to
introduce dr. Dan Rhoades the head of
compendium Biosciences business unit and
vice president of medical science
informatics dan will be presenting a bio
informatics approach to sequencing
cancer samples at the end of Dan's
presentation I'll be facilitating QA so
feel free to submit questions during his
presentation dan great thank you my
queen is real pleasure to be speaking it
to you today we've got an exciting story
to tell we're going to talk about how
really we're merging Ion Torrent
technology with bioinformatics and
genomic analysis to identify the
important genetic events in cancer and
build cancer sequencing solutions to
really power the next generation of
clinical research what I'm going to talk
to you today is about life technologies
goal to ultimately democratize
sequencing for cancer we imagine a world
in which cancers are universally
sequenced streamlined informatics allows
us to interpret and understand those
sequences and ultimately to link
sequences to therapies and clinical
trials of interest so the two key
questions that we're going to address
today are given the state of
next-generation sequencing and
sequencing and cancer we're to try to
answer two important questions what are
the jeans and the specific regions of
genes that we need to measure one of the
most relevant informative genes and then
ultimately what would we like to report
out when a cancer sample is positive
for a particular genetic alteration so
two simple questions but important ones
we're going to talk about our
bioinformatics strategy to really
leverage all of the world's content all
of the information that's available to
us in the public domain to answer those
two important questions so before we get
into the bioinformatics let's talk a
little bit about the Ion Torrent
technology it is truly a transformative
technology and the team at ion torrent
has made unprecedented progress in the
last couple of years really going from a
sequencing concept to relatively mature
sequencing technology and that's because
the Ion Torrent technology leverages the
semiconductor industry and leverages the
cumulative investment that that industry
has made over the last 30 years the
chips that we produce for Ion Torrent
are the same chips that are produced is
are produced in the same semiconductor
factories that the chips that exist in
our iPhones are produced so let's let's
talk a little bit about the technology
so instead of instead of sensing photons
as is done in an image sensor the
ionship senses protons these hydrogen
ions that come off of DNA as the
sequencing is occurring the cross
sectional view here shows the ion
sensitive layer in green the micro Wells
on top and the transistor stack
underneath so then we pair this scalable
semi conductor technology with a very
simple chemistry to arrive at a highly
competitive sequencing solution our
simple natural chemistry eliminates a
number of sources of error in light
based sequencing and provides us a
number of advantages minimizing read
link levitating limitations a natural
basis slow cycle time that results from
this protect d protect cycle so that's
the technology platform we're leveraging
we've already made tremendous progress
in sequencing cancer samples with ion
torrent technology if you're not already
familiar
with our eye on damn + C cancer panel
this is a truly remarkable product so
this product is focused on measuring 46
cancer genes and the key hotspots in
each of these cancer genes covering
important genes at EGFR and B wrath and
K rass only 10 nano grams of DNA is
required now a number of publications
demonstrating that from limited
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
material a small amount of DNA these key
cancer mutations can be read out readily
and routinely we've also launched a
product called the comprehensive cancer
panel this product seeks to probe 400
important cancer genes but now
sequencing not just hot spots but in
fact all exons in these important cancer
genes an informatics product that we've
recently launched the ion reporter
alkaline workflow allows scientists to
rapidly run the hotspot panel or the
comprehensive panel and layer on
important annotations from the online
database allowing the researcher to go
very quickly from sample to sequence to
meaningful driver genetic variants in a
cancer sample the product concept that
I'll be talking to you about today is
what we've called the arm combined
cancer panel the idea here is let's
leverage a bioinformatics approach to
survey all available genomic and
clinical research data to arrive at the
complete set of informative cancer
drivers so will now begin to assess not
just mutations but also key copy number
events as well as gene fusions we're
combining a DNA sequencing and RNA
sequencing workflow to cover all three
of these important genetic events and
our vision is a turnkey informatics and
reporting solution to empower any
clinical cancer researcher to go from
cancer sample to informative driver
genetic events and relevant clinical
search related to those genetic events
so that's the vision and today I'm going
to tell you about the important
bioinformatics work that we've done to
move us closer to realizing that vision
what we've done is taken a systematic
data-driven approach to define the
content that we desire to measure on the
on combined cancer panel so the two
questions I alluded to earlier what to
measure and what to report actually if
you take a data-driven approach it's the
same data the same knowledge that drives
the what to rip what to measure question
the content question as as as the what
to report question so if we do this
right we can collect all of this
important information and knowledge and
that tells us both what do we need to
measure from a mutations copy number
events and gene fusions perspective but
then also what are the important pieces
of information that we need to report
out on the relevant on the relevance of
these alterations I'm going to tell you
about our information informative driver
genetic events knowledge base and the
information systems that we're building
to keep this knowledge base up-to-date
as new information becomes available to
us in the public domain this knowledge
base really has two main components the
first is the genetic drivers of cancer
so what genetic events can take part in
tumorigenesis in causing a cancer cell
or cancer clone to emerge and we're
spanning as I mentioned three important
classes of driver genetic events but
then also what information exists in the
public domain to link these driver
genetic events to potential treatments
or clinical trials you know really let's
let's filter these driver genetic events
down to those that are truly informative
from a clinical research perspective
this information spans a number of
sources so which genetic events are on
label for fda-approved drugs which
genetic events show up in clinical
guidelines which genetic events have
early clinical
search data suggesting that they linked
to a responder or a non-responder
population which genetic events are
clinical trial enrollment criteria for
pharma clinical trials already today and
which have preclinical information or
are simply targeted by either an
approved drug or an emerging
investigational drug but don't yet have
any evidence linking the drug to the
genetic event so our goal here is to
assemble all available knowledge related
to genetic driver events as well as
information sources that can link
genetic events to potential therapies so
that's what we're aiming for in the top
we're going to step through each of
these each of these areas each of these
driver genetic event types as well as
each of these clinical information
sources and then at the end we'll talk
about how we put it all together to
build a cancer sequencing solution
really from from the sequencing kit all
the way to the informatik analysis and
and ultimately the reporting solution so
let's begin let's begin by walking
through the genetic drivers of cancer
starting with mutations so to get a
handle on the mutations that actually
matter in cancer the mutations that are
actually a causal in cancer what we've
tried to do is assemble all available
cancer sequencing data we're leveraging
data sources such as the Cancer Genome
Atlas which now is up to about 5,000
cancer exomes as well as published data
from from the literature we've
identified about 30 or 40 additional
studies on bringing our total to close
to 10,000 published cancer exomes we've
also incorporated data from the
important cosmic database as well so
let's talk about our approach with
mutations what we've found upon
surveying all of this mutation data and
examining the cancer genes that we know
well and understand is we found
signatures mutation signatures for both
oncogenes and tumor suppressor genes
and to state it very simply on the
signature the mutation signature for an
oncogene is positive for hotspot
mutations and negative for deleterious
mutations now let me define those terms
so a hotspot mutation is any any
mutation that essentially piles up at a
particular amino acid locus in the
protein so there are a number of these
hotspot mutations that we all know well
in the beer a protein v600e mutation is
the most common mutation that's a hot
spot mutation the kr sg12 mutation is a
hotspot mutation as well what we found
is that when we serve a known oncogenes
they all have this characteristic
pattern predominance of hotspot
mutations and almost non occurring or
rare deleterious mutations so let me
show you an example we're looking here
at the mutation signature for pi3 kinase
alpha in our database we have observed
490 mutations in pi3 kinase for a total
mutation frequency of sixteen percent
but the remarkable thing is that
eighty-five percent of these mutations
occur at hotspots and we can see that
here in the lower panel so as we look at
the amino acid positions for which we
have observed pi3 kinase mutations we
can see that these mutations certainly
pile up at hot spots so the most
prominent hotspot the H 1047 are
mutation more than a hundred cases with
mutation at this site the second most
common hotspot of the e 5 45 mutation
again more than a hundred mutations then
we can see a number of other less
frequent hotspots are 88 q + 3 45 k e 7
26 k so overall eighty-five percent of
pi3 kinase alpha mutations occurring at
one of these small number of hotspot
mutations the characteristic signature
for a non
so when we think about cancer sequencing
we actually don't need to measure the
full pi3 kinase gene you just need to
focus on these pi3 kinase hotspots and
the more cancers we sequence more
resolution we gain on these true hotspot
mutations the interesting thing from a
drug development perspective is that
these pi3 kinase mutations are not just
occurring in the couple of cancer types
in which they were originally identified
apologize for the coding here but each
of these bars each of these bars
represents a different cancer type so
uterine cancer breast cancer cervical
cancer and what we found when we survey
exomes systematically across thousands
of tumors is that in fact pi3k hotspot
mutations coated in pink occur in nearly
every cancer type tested so it's not
just the uterine cancers and breast
cancers and cervical cancers that were
that these pi3 kinase mutations were
originally identified in in fact these
pi3k hotspot mutations are occurring in
stomach cancers colon cancers lung
cancers and even rarely in kidney
cancers and prostate cancers these same
hotspot mutations occurring repeatedly
across the whole number of cancers so
this tells us this data-driven
systematic analysis tells us which
mutations likely matter based on this
characteristic signature of this
mutation signature for Naga gene now
we've applied this bio informatics
approach to all of the exome data that
I've described and from that we've
identified all of the genes that have
recurrent hotspot mutations and the
wonderful thing is is that this really
covers all of the known oncogenes known
to be activated by a mutations in cancer
but this also identifies a number of
novel potential lanka genes that have
this characteristic hot spot pattern so
that's the oncogene mutations signature
that we've observed and then used as a
filter to search through all of the
exome data to nominate cancer drivers
that need to be measured by our next gen
sequencing test now let's talk about
tumor suppressor genes
tumor suppressor genes when we examine
their mutation signature tend to have a
characteristic pattern that is a
combination of both hotspot mutations
and deleterious mutations let me define
deleterious mutation but in our analysis
we're defining deleterious mutations as
those mutations that are either nonsense
mutations resulting in a truncated
protein or frameshift insertions and
deletions some you so insertions and
deletions that put the protein out of
frame and basically render it a non
functional protein so those are two
classes of mutations that we know are
deleterious there are also likely
missense mutations that are deleterious
but that we can't be certain based on
the classification so the interesting
thing is is when we look at all of the
known to suppressor genes mutated in
cancers of p53 a cdkn2a rb1 all of these
genes have this characteristic pattern a
disproportionate fraction of their
mutations are either hotspot mutations
or deleterious mutations I'm showing you
here a gene I would say a relatively
recently discovered tumor suppressor
gene arid 1a this is a chromatin
modifying gene this is a gene that has
this characteristic tumor suppressor
mutation signature so in this early
analysis we had 3,000 patients with XM
analysis 6.9 percent mutation frequency
and fifty five point eight percent of
those mutations clearly deleterious this
is entirely non-random given that the
background deleterious mutation rate is
only on the order of five to seven
percent so in a gene like Jared 1a when
we see fifty five percent of these
mutations as truncating mutations or
frameshift mutations we can be
relatively sure that this is a selected
for mutational signature and aired 1a is
a functional driver a tumor suppressor
gene the blue bars represent the
proportion of the mutations that are in
fact deleterious in nature and you can
see that we're seeing deleterious
mutations and Erin
uterine gladder stomach cervical quorum
and a whole number of cancers as well so
we believe that Erin 1a is a driver
tumor suppressor gene based on the
systemic mutation analysis so those are
two genes pik3ca and aired 1a that we
all know well let me tell you about a
gene that this approach discovered a
potential novel oncogene in this case so
we all know b-raf and the B rafi 600e
mutation it's been well targeted in
melanoma by the maratha NIV and other
tournament therapies our analysis on our
analysis uncovered another raft family
member raf1 that also has hotspot
mutations they're relatively rare but
they do tend to pile up at particular
amino acid positions suggesting that
these raf-1 mutations are drivers as
well one of these hotspots the S 257 L
mutation we observe that mutation four
times in our analysis but the fact that
the mutations piled up at this one site
was non-random and that statistical
significance this hotspot mutation
though we wouldn't have found if we
looked at any one of these cancer types
independently we only identified this
hotspot mutation we put all of this data
together and found that one stomach
cancer patient one uterine cancer
patient a colon cancer patient a rectal
cancer patient and a lung cancer patient
all had this same c-raf mutation
suggesting that this non random pattern
is suggestive of a novel oncogenic
driver in cancer as it turns out this s
257 L mutation has been observed in the
germline and is associated with a
syndrome called Noonan syndrome it's
been shown that this is a functionally
activating mutation in the rap one gene
so what we're observing here is somatic
mutation in raf-1 at this hotspot these
mutations are mutually exclusive with K
rats and beer at mutations in these
diseases further suggestive of that this
is a novel oncogenic driver so even
though pharmaceutical companies haven't
begun directly targeting RAF
mutations with it with therapies these
hotspot mutations are important to
measure because they may turn out to be
markers of response to RAF inhibitors
Clint in the clinic so so this would be
an example of a novel mutation that
we've identified that we're going to
include on our cancer sequencing panel
okay so that's mutations and that's our
data-driven approach to use mutation
signatures to really define the
mutations that matter for our for our
cancer sequencing panel let's not talk
about copy number so I think we all know
that copy number events are almost
equally important in human cancer there
are a number of examples the most
notable being her two in breast and Gant
gastric cancer or high-level focal
amplification of the her to uncle
protein leads to activated signaling and
also leads to a response to drugs like
trastuzumab and pertuzumab so the
question is what are the other driver
genetic focal amplifications that occur
in cancer one approach would be to go to
the literature and to try to survey the
literature for these activated driver
genetic events but but here we're taking
a data-driven approach really trying to
look at systematic genome analysis to
arrive at an unbiased list of driver
genetic events and we're doing the same
thing for copy number data for copy
number data we can benefit from all of
the work that was done on the microarray
so we have amassed more than 25,000
micro arrays assessing DNA copy number
and we can use that data to ask what are
the key focal driver amplifications in
human cancer to illustrate our analysis
I'm showing you a gene that you may be
familiar with fgfr1 this is a gene
that's been being targeted by a whole
number of investigational agents on the
pharmaceutical industry when we look at
the profile the copy number profile for
fgfr1 what we can see is that as we look
across a whole number of cancer types
and in this view more than 10,000 tumors
for which we've assessed fgfr1 copy
number we can see that most of the
tumors have somewhere around two copies
of fgfr1 so that your normal diploid
state but some cancer specifically in
breast cancer lung cancers and ovarian
cancers have elevated fgfr1 copy number
now the question is are these fgfr1 DNA
amplifications true cancer drivers or
are these cases where for example the
whole chromosome the whole eight Pete
chromosome arm is amplified and fgfr1
happens to be coming along for the ride
it's really our belief and I think
what's what's panned out in the
literature that only if a gene tends to
be highly and focally amplified can we
can we really be certain that it's the
true the true genetic driver in the
region of genes that are amplified so
how can we get to that for a gene like
fgfr1 so in this next slide what I'm
showing you a drill-down view of the
individual tumors for which we have
observed fgfr1 amplification and the
boundaries of the amplifications that
we've observed so what we've got here
are what we've got here are genes in the
fgfr1 neighborhood so here's fdf are one
right in the middle of this plot we've
got jeans ordered in chromosome order
sort of upstream and downstream of fgfr1
and then on the y axis we have the
ovarian cancer patients that had fgfr1
amplification in fact we have 18 of 841
ovarian cancer patients with fgfr1
amplification it's 2.1 percent so each
row is one of these ovarian cancer
tumors that that was measured by
microarray and for which we we have
collected the data and what you can see
is some of these amplification span you
know a couple of dozen genes some of
these amplifications are like the one
here in the middle I include only three
genes and here's another one down a bit
further on amplification that includes
only two genes so when we look at all
data and we attempt to summarize it down
below here now in the plot where we're
tallying up for each gene the number of
cases with amplification in blue and the
degree of those amplifications in pink
what we can see is that in fact there is
a focal region here right around fgfr1
that represents the minimal common
region of amplification what that
suggests is that fgfr1 and maybe a
neighbor or two are likely the drivers
of this amplification because in each of
the tumors experiencing amplification in
this region that fgfr region is always
amplified so that gives us good
confidence that fgfr1 is indeed a cancer
driver here in ovarian cancer we can we
can gain even more confidence by looking
at gene expression data so here now on
the x-axis we've got copy number of
fgfr1 across the whole collection of
tumors and then on the y axis we have
expression importantly we see that we
see that when fgfr1 is amplified those
cases also show overexpression of fgfr1
so this amplification is functional in
the sense that it leads to elevated
expression now there are other cases
that also have a overexpression of fgfr1
that do not have amplification that but
that's not to say that these amplified
cases leading to overexpression are not
drivers so this gives us confidence that
fgfr1 is an important driver amplified
gene in human cancer and thus we need to
have this gene on our cancer panel we
need to be able to assess fgfr1 so we've
done a similar analysis sort of
genome-wide examining all genes and
examining their copy number profiles the
minimum common regions around
amplifications and deletions and co
amplification co expression pattern to
arrive at what we believe are the true
set of driver genetic events that are
activated idea
amplification okay so that's mutations
and that's copy number events at the end
I'll summarize and tell you the number
of genes we've identified in each of
these buckets but now let's first talk
about gene fusions so historically gene
fusions have been identified with
chromosomal techniques karyotyping you
know that how the Philadelphia
chromosome BCR Abel and chronic
myelogenous leukemia was identified as
well as a number of others but just
recently really with the advent of RNA
sequencing have we been able to take a
data data driven systematic or a
transcriptome scale approach toward gene
fusion discovery and we'll tell you
about the work we've done in this space
so we're fortunate from the Cancer
Genome Atlas to have access to now more
than 5,000 cancer transcriptomes we also
have fantastic reference databases and
cosmic and middlemen really surveying
all of the historic literature on gene
fusions but it really is this this new
RNA seek transcriptome data that allows
us for the first time to survey tumors
for gene fusions that are likely
important genetic drivers and cancer so
let me tell you a little bit about our
work in gene fusions so as I mentioned
we've processed more than 5,000
transcriptomes to date this is no small
task in fact we have we've had to build
up a very loud a large cloud grid
computing infrastructure to run through
all of these samples we've developed
state-of-the-art methods really adapting
the methods that are out there in the
public domain for our use we've done
very intensive training and testing to
make sure that our algorithms can can
lead us towards true positive gene
fusions while filtering out the false
positives I'll show you we've made a
really important that's a lot of
methodological advance in layering in
what we call axon expression imbalance
analysis and trained our method on
dozens of gold standard positive gene
fusions that we know should exist in the
population if our method is performing
examples of those gold standard
positives include pml rora
and run x1 and AML AML for elk and Ross
one fusions in lung adenocarcinoma and
then the X fusions genes in prostate
cancers so what I'm depicting here on
the right in this bar chart is really
our early training set of RNA seek data
where we had access to a large amount of
RNA seek data we knew which fusions we
expect it to find in this data and then
we could tune our algorithms to make
sure that they were in fact finding
these cold standards so we've done that
and but now we've turned the algorithms
on to these five thousand transcriptomes
and and really validated all of the gene
fusions that we expect it to find but
also have discovered a whole number of
novel gene fusions many of them we
believe will be informative in clinical
cancer research so let's look at some
data so first here I'm showing you a few
visualizations of the EML for elk gene
fusions that we identified from
systematic bioinformatic analysis of RNA
seek data so first in the top panel I'm
showing you the exon representation of
the fusions that we identify so on the
left in green we've got the five prime
partner EML for and on the right in pink
we have the three prime partner elk and
what we're representing on the x-axis
are the number of exons that participate
in the resulting gene fusion what we can
see is that for these three gene fusions
observed in three independent tumor
samples we can see that in all three
cases we've got the same exon structure
for elk so ten coding exons and one one
or two non coding exons but we've got
variable X on structure for AML four so
two of the gene fusions identified with
seven coding exons of EML for the third
with 13 coding exons so this view gives
us a sense for the structure of these
gene fusions and this is important when
we are identifying novel gene fusions to
ask the question hey are we seeing a
consistent exon structure in the gene
fusions that leads us to believe that
these are in fact bona fide drive
gene fusions so that's sort of step one
calling the gene fusions based on reads
that cross the gene fusion boundary
examine the exon structure but the step
to really is it is looking at the exxon
expression levels and asking the
question do the exon expression levels
are they consistent with gene fusions so
what I'd like to do is draw your
attention to this panel here in the
middle where we're looking at ELQ
expression levels across all of the
exons in elk each tumor sample is
represented by a line the gene fusion
positive cases by red lines the gene
fusion negative cases by blue lines what
we can see is as we march across the elk
transcript from five prime to three
prime we can see that both for the
fusion positive and the fusion negative
cases there's basically no expression
about but in the fusion positive cases
we see a jump in expression in elk right
at the predicted break point which is
designated by the red dymond so we see
this exon expression imbalance with
increased expression post breakpoint
relative to pre breakpoint and we're
only seeing that pattern in the fusion
positive cases this is basically
confirmatory analysis using the same RNA
seat data to predict the gene fusion but
also to validate the gene fusion by
quantifying expression levels pre and
post breakpoint we think it's a very
elegant method it really is an
orthogonal data analysis but leveraging
the same underlying RNA seek data so
we've applied this method then across
all of the available data and we of
course find all of the fusions in these
tumors that we know and expect but
importantly we've discovered a whole
number of novel gene fusions in cancer
I'll give you one example because it has
such important clinical relevance we
discovered actually a handful of elk
gene fusions in colorectal cancer these
are just now
to be reported in the literature that
this observation we made well over a
year ago a handful of novel gene fusions
and colon cancer but also in a lot of
half a dozen additional solid tumors
importantly this pyaar kar one al fusion
has the same elk exon exon structure as
the EML for elk exons with ten coding
exons and when we look at the exxon
expression data we get this same exon
expression imbalance with a jumpin
expression with a jump and expression
post breakpoint in the in the fusion
positive case relative to the fusion
negative cases so our belief is that
this is a bona fide novel elf fusion
given that EML for elf fusions have been
well targeted in lung cancer it seems
important that these additional out
fusion be measured for clinical cancer
research going forward so that's gene
fusions now we've covered mutations copy
number alterations and gene fusions and
we've built really the first half of the
informative driver genetic events
knowledgebase focusing on the driver
genetic events now let's talk about the
information sources we want to bring to
bear to really get to which of these
driver genetic events are informative or
make treatments and trials perspective
so a whole number of data sources that
we've surveyed compiled and analyzed I'm
just going to tell you about some of the
work that we've done on a couple of
these data sources when we talk about
when we talk about on label this is a
pretty simple data source to curate here
we go to the FDA website and we can
simply read what are all of the genetic
events that show up on drug labels these
are of course important genetic events
to study they're so important that
they've landed on a drug label so that's
one class I'm not going to talk to you
about that anymore similarly with
clinical guidelines we've simply
surveyed the NCCN I'm as coke clinical
guidelines and identified all the cases
where 10
our genetic drivers of cancer shows up
in the clinical guidelines and
documented all of us what i will do is
tell you about some some very exciting
work we've done to summarize clinical
trial results in the literature
pertaining to stratification by genetic
events but also clinical trial
enrollment criteria so if we look at
clinical trials that pharmaceutical
companies or academic investigators are
sponsoring we can survey those clinical
trials look at the inclusion criteria
sections and identify a whole number of
cases where genetic biomarkers are being
used today as inclusion criteria for
clinical trials these that are of course
important genetic biomarkers to measure
on a cancer sequencing panel to get the
most out of a clinical cancer research
study in fact you know to summarize that
data we've identified more than 50
genetic events that show up in more than
a thousand clinical trials as inclusion
criteria for nearly 300 targeted
therapies so this is not just you know a
small area of clinical research today
this is becoming the norm more than a
thousand clinical trials covering 300
drugs using more than 50 genetic markers
as inclusion criteria so that's an
important collection of data we really
need to have our arms around in an
updated manner such that we can
understand which genetic events are
important for clinical research we'll
also talk a little bit about our efforts
to compile preclinical information to
identify informative markers and then
also simply drug target databases so
first let's talk about clinical trial
results data binding as well as
enrollment criteria so what we've built
is a really a semi automated data mining
strategy we're combining sort of the
best of natural language processing to
parse clinical trial results and
clinical trial enrollment criteria but
also that
we're layering in expert data curation
by my PhD scientists so what we found is
that our automated data mining
approaches can really get us to the
trials and the results sections that
matter but it really takes a human I a
trained human eye to pull out those
those relevant facts so let me show you
an example here's an as Co abstract on a
phase 2 clinical study of debrecen abbr
being tested in me Rath mutant
non-small-cell lung cancers so what our
data mining approach does is goes and
looks for keywords that are related to
our driver genetic events of interest so
if you remember you know we talked about
b-raf so if we find the word b-raf and a
clinical trial result but then if we
also find keywords that might suggest
that there is a clinical trial result
related to be reputation such as PR SD
and pd these are standard acronyms for
partial response stable disease
progressive disease as part of resist
criteria or keywords like orr which
stands for overall response rate then we
know we found a relevant record so the
data mining takes us to this record but
then our expert curator says okay we've
got an interesting result here in fact
the president was tested specifically in
v600e mutant lung cancers treated with
the president and a fifty-four percent
overall response rate was observed so
this tells us both that b-raf is
important to measure from a clinical
research perspective but also if the
clinical researcher is running our
cancer panel has a BF a result turn up
in lung cancer this is an important
piece of research to point that clinical
researcher to to understand the
relevance of that finding okay let's
talk a little bit about a preclinical
information there have been a whole
number of really wonderful studies by by
the sanger center the Broad Institute
studies published by a GSK
large collections of human cancer cell
lines have been probed with a whole
number of drugs both investigational and
fda-approved drugs and in parallel these
cell lines have been profiled by a whole
number of genomic profiling technologies
so what we've done is we've brought all
of that data in and we've asked the
question which of our driver genetic
events show up as informative predictive
biomarkers in these preclinical cell
line models so we've done this
systematically across all of the data
that's available let me show you an
example so here we're looking at
negative log I see 50s on the y-axis so
for cell lines treated with a drug
called PES openeth now please open it
was really marketed as a veg f inhibitor
but like many of these receptor tyrosine
kinase inhibitors has off target effects
and blocks a number of receptor tyrosine
kinases so what I'm showing you here are
the negative log I see 50s across the
whole panel of a couple of hundred cell
lines each cell line is a bar what we
see is that a small fraction of the cell
lines a small fraction of the cell lines
are sensitive over here on the left
whereas the majority of the cell lines
are resistant over here on the right
when we ask the question do any of our
driver genetic events associate with
sensitivity what we find is that fgfr2
amplified cell lines tend to be on the
sensitive side now there are only three
of these cell lines colored in pink but
the fact that all three of these cell
lines show up on the sensitive side of
the distribution is highly statistically
significant and suggests from this
preclinical information that fgfr2
amplification may be informative for the
treatment of treatment with fgfr
inhibitors such as his opening
interestingly we recently saw a reports
from that Myerson at the broad that an
fgfr2 amplified patient actually had
had a tumor regression response from
treatment with PES open now this is just
a single case study but it substantiates
to some degree this pre clinical
observation and really this approach of
using preclinical data to nominate
potentially informative cancer markers
I'll show you another example here we're
looking at the same type of a plot where
we've got cell lines in this case
treated with a drug called trim metonym
tremendum is a mek inhibitor from
glaxosmithkline we see that we've got a
sensitive cell lines on the Left
resistant cell lines on the right when
we ask the question which of our genetic
events associate with sensitivity
resistance we can see that n Rask mutate
mutated cell lines in pink tend to be
sensitive no Ann Rasmussen lines on the
resistance side so again a potentially
informative genetic marker relevant for
a treatment like tremendum in converse
when we look at a p.i 3 kinase inhibitor
bez 235 this is an investigational agent
and we look at its profile across cell
lines and rasmussen tend to show up on
the resistant end of the spectrum so
again unrest may be an informative
mutation for treatment with PES 235 and
other pi3k inhibitors but informative of
the sense of lack of response again this
is just preclinical information probably
not something that not not not data that
would be used to make clinical decisions
but does tell us about markers that are
potentially informative and important to
measure on our cancer panel so we've
done an analysis just like this
systematically across all of the genetic
events and all of the this preclinical
data that we've been able to accumulate
to arrive at what we believe are the
informative genetic events from
preclinical data okay so let me tell you
a little bit about then the the
informative genetic events reference
that we've built so what I'm showing you
here this is an internal tool set but
really just a view on the knowledge base
that we've created and what we're doing
here is we're surveying one of our
markers
elk and we're seeing that across the
informative data sources that we've
assembled help shows up in a number of
places elk shows up in clinical
guidelines one time there's one approved
therapy a croissant nib that targets elk
there are six investigational therapies
that also target out that are in various
phases of clinical development and there
are 12 marker based trials that are
specifically enrolling patients without
gene fusions covering nine drugs and
those trials are summarized here down
below so by assembling all of this
information we both informed which
markers we need to measure on our cancer
panel but also we are beginning to
accumulate the data that will be
interesting to our customers that are
engaged in clinical research and are
measuring these markers in their studies
so with that now I've summarized for you
our bioinformatics approach to look for
to systematically define the genetic
drivers of cancer but also specifically
those drivers that are important
formative for clinical research when we
combine drivers and informative or
actionable markers we arrive at
interestingly a relatively short list of
genes so about a in together about 130
genes many of these genes show them both
in the mutated and the copy number the
mutated and the gene fusions list about
130 genes that we believe our
data-driven approach suggests there's
evidence that they are genetic drivers
of cancer but also are in some regard
clinically are informative as it
pertains to clinical research so this is
this is the content that we're now
beginning to build out on the Ion
Torrent platform as the oncoming cancer
panel they're getting a view into our
future direction as we imagine this
future product vision we imagine an amp
Lisey kit for measuring DNA another RNA
seat kit for measuring RNA focusing on
the gene fusions and some important gene
expression markers
sequencing tumor samples using both of
these kits and the ion PGM or personal
genome machine of the ion 318 chip were
we're building out now really a turnkey
informatics workflow both to make
variant calls but also to layer on all
of this important driver and informative
clinical research data that we've
accumulated so that our clinical
research customers can very quickly
understand the potential relevance of
the variants coming off of this panel so
this is what we're building we're very
excited about it we think we think this
this product concept has the ability to
really allow a broad set of clinical
cancer researchers to survey the
important driver genetic events in human
cancer just a couple of slides before I
wrap up to show proof of concept so
we've got a number of studies now in the
literature showing that we can very
accurately detect single nucleotide
variants with ion torrent and amp lassie
from formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue with very small sample
requirements down to ten nanograms of
DNA what I'm showing you here is proof
of concept data that actually I on am
plus ich is also very good and very
accurate for detecting DNA copy number
level and this is important as we saw
because a whole number of genes are
activated by amplification what I'm
showing you here is really that we're
seeing a very similar copy number
profile when we look using ion torrent
analysis and we look using array CGH
technology this is this is just a
glimmer of the early feasibility studies
we've done but it shows you that we can
accurately measure a copy number by
next-gen sequencing and similarly on the
next slide this is work that we've done
to show that we can accurately detect
gene fusions by RNA seek using
next-generation sequencing what we have
here as rows are a serial dilution of a
positive gene fusion an EML for elk gene
fusion from a lung adenocarcinoma cell
line we
diluting that down with normal RNA from
human brain across the columns we have a
whole number of gene fusions for which
we have primers that span the potential
gene fusion one primer in the five prime
gene one primer in the three prime gene
and what we can see here is that this
particular cell line which is positive
for a single specific EML 4l fusion rrna
seek analysis by my eye on sequencing is
only lighting up this this one gene
fusion and you can see we can detect
that all the way down to a one percent
1% dilution and none of the other gene
fusions in the mix are lighting up so
what this shows is that in a in a highly
multiplex manner we can detect gene
fusions down to a very low quantity in
the sample so it's very exciting that we
can now measure accurately single
nucleotide variants copy number events
and gene fusions really spanning all of
the important driver genetic events in
cancer for those of you engaged in
research if you're interested in gaining
access to some of the bioinformatics
analysis that we've done I would like to
make you aware of a really fantastic
product line that we've launched called
the Anka mine next generation sequencing
power tools these power tools allow our
users to drill into all the exome and
transcriptome data the mutations the
gene fusions the copy number event to
really understand important driver
genetic events in cancer this tool set
is being used by a whole number of large
pharmaceutical companies engaged in drug
discovery and development but is also
now beginning these tools are beginning
to be used by clinical cancer
researchers in conjunction with Ion
Torrent sequencing to basically answer
the question you know after you do
sequencing and you get a whole number of
variants that come out which of those
variants are likely to be driver genetic
events that are worth following up on so
this tool sets available if you're
interested in learning more about the
work that I described the cancer
panel that we're developing or these
tools i invite you to visit our booth
our online booth in the meeting so with
that let me conclude and thank all the
teams involved this is this has really
been a group effort across a number of
divisions and life technologies so our
new medical sciences division the
competitive bioscience team in Ann Arbor
the Ion Torrent team as well as the am
beyond team we've really all come
together to assemble the best of life
technologies in terms of sequencing in
terms of DNA and RNA analysis and in
terms of bioinformatics and our hope is
that we'll be able to deliver to you a
very remarkable set of products from
these efforts so thank you for your
attention and I'm happy to take any
questions michaelene let me turn it back
over to you thank you Dan our first
question is from Tiffany what
sensitivity in percent of reeds do you
use is a cut off to say a given mutation
is present in the sample what is your
cutoff for the total number of reads for
each amplicon before you proceed with
making a call
well great question thank you for that
so we're looking at what we're making
calls in a couple of settings so in the
first setting we're really looking at
data we've accumulated from the research
domain and we're making we're making
variant calls from that data in that
case we tend to be a little less
stringent because we're in discovery
mode but when we talk about when we talk
about sequencing on the Ion Torrent for
clinical research use what we're really
targeting is a analysis that get to at
least ten percent we want to cover at
least ten percent allele frequency we're
using a statistical model basically to
say do we have do we statistically have
more variants observed in the tumor than
we would expect by chance but we're
targeting that ten percent allele
frequency and we really need to see you
know on the order of five or ten variant
reads to make a call and pass the
statistical threshold but but in fact
with the panel that we're developing
we're sequencing to such depth you know
we're sequencing to an average depth of
500 x that in most cases when we're
targeting that ten percent of lil
frequency we're seeing on the order of
50 plus variant alleles even if even in
that ten percent allele frequency
scenario
thank you Dan our next question is from
Moritz is the data on drugs and trials
included in the uncle mind tools yeah
great question the answer is not yet
we're really accumulating that data to
guide to guide the development of the
cancer panel but it is our long-term
vision to layer all of that information
on drugs into the online tools and make
those available to our research
customers but but not quite yet Thank
You our next questions from Anna how
much material from a biopsy is necessary
for both DNA and RNA expression studies
another good question because we're
using anti-sikh we can get the sample
requirements down really quite low 10
nano grams is the requirement on both
sides for DNA and RNA but but please
note for the RNA seek studies that I've
just described we're really focusing on
only a small number of gene expression
markers and on a large pool of gene
fusions but but but we know that really
in most cases you know zero to one or
two of those gene fusions are going to
turn on positive so so the answer is 10
nanograms and we think that's really one
of the key differentiators for the Ion
Torrent and am plac'd platforms
thank you the next question is from
sarahvani how do you validate the data
mining results you get from preclinical
studies a great question you know it's
always tough to validate a single
preclinical result you know we really
try to use multiple independent data
sets to validate one another so for
example in the fgfr result that I showed
you I only showed you the PES open of
data that showed that fgfr2
amplification associated with
sensitivity took his opening but we in
fact had a couple of other fgfr
inhibitors that showed that exact same
pattern so we try to use independent
preclinical data sets to validate one
another but the truth is you know that
the data sort of is what it is it's you
know it's early preclinical data for us
it represents a hypothesis that suggests
that a particular genetic event may be
associated may be informative an
informative biomarker but we really
won't know that until we can begin to
collect clinical data in larger clinical
studies but but that early hypothesis
for us is good enough to say that's an
important marker it needs to be measured
on the panel and in that early
preclinical data may be informative and
interesting to a clinical researcher as
they're getting clinical sequencing
results
the next question is when is from waffle
what is the difference between I n
torrents and the other sequences
sequencers used yeah that's a great
question you know there are certainly
other sequences on the market we believe
that ion torrent has ultimately superior
technology for sequencing DNA leading to
lower error rates in for detecting
single nucleotide variants also i think
you know sort of if i had to decide to
put my finger on key differentiator for
the application that I'm describing that
I've described today there really are
two its sample input so the fact that we
can get down to 10 nano grams of DNA
from formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue but and then also turn around
time we can complete the entire workflow
really from sample from from sample in
to analyze sample in less than a day and
that just can't be done on other
sequencing platforms thank you Dan I
believe we have time for just one more
question that question is from Adam do
you think these genetic drivers will
have diagnostic usage in the future
yeah great question you know that that's
that's our view that that ultimately
these genetic drivers will become
important diagnostic markers if you look
at the important diagnostic markers
today so b-raf egfr k r a CML for elk
all of these markers represent genetic
drivers of cancer and and because they
represent distinct mechanisms and
pathways to activate cancer you know
logically they're leading to
differential response to targeted
therapies so it's our view that as the
pharmaceutical industry attempts to
target more and more of these genetic
drivers of cancer these genetic drivers
then become important diagnostic markers
so today many of these markers are
really only important for clinical
research but ultimately we believe as as
the therapies as the investigation Alera
peace progress towards approval many of
these markers become important
diagnostic markers as well I'd like to
thank everybody for their attention
thank you for the questions it's been a
pleasure I hope this was useful to you
thanks I'm going to turn it back over to
you Michael lean back over to mine thank
you and at this point we'll go ahead and
conclude this session and thank all the
participants